[Music]
that dude alex reminds me of shan like
they both
have ancient genes okay you know yeah
like they're original humans yeah and it
makes me think how we have completely
lost the genetic lottery
[Laughter]
me and you've yeah okay
we are girls actually no that's not even
fair we are infants yeah you know in
terms of human performance we are
we are meant for computers yep i sure
feel like an infant after coastal g yeah
had our way with us yeah i mean even
standing next to ike yeah i just laugh
i'm like we what do you mean even
standing next to him he's like the
special like he's one of the biggest
people on earth
yeah yeah ike's got ancient genes too
yeah for sure yeah i shouldn't say just
yeah i guess what i mean by that is even
just walking around him the first time
yeah i'm like i'm a i'm a child yeah i'm
genetically a child i don't know why
this reminds me of this but there's this
video on tick tock i'm gonna try and
find it one of the biggest dudes i've
ever seen just in terms of bodybuilding
sure not big stature wise but had the
biggest muscles i think i've ever seen
oh he's doing rows with like
like one like dumbbell rows
like single single hand right and
pulling up like i don't even know what's
a crazy number for rose like 300 pounds
or something like 250 like a peanut or
like a barbell like a dumbbell dumbbell
sorry um yeah like a p like here let me
just find the video
but anyways all the comments are like i
mean rowing [ __ ] a hundred is pretty
intense yeah and i'm pretty sure this
was like in the 200s and the comments
are all like bro didn't do one rep wow
zero reps completed like they're people
picking on his technique yeah when this
guy is clearly the biggest dude on earth
yeah do you ever ponder your
interest in fitness
possibly being just a massive insecurity
um yeah
yeah i don't
okay that's just you okay oh worse
okay no for sure okay so
i mean that's a pretty solid rep
like i mean
his back is
i don't know what the [ __ ] anyone's
talking about dude but like even even
saying oh no that's a rep like neither
of us are qualified to tell this guy
what a rep is he clearly [ __ ] knows
what's working anyone in his comments
like my full rep i'm pretty sure this
guy could hang you by a [ __ ] rope
and like row you yeah
so just shut up just shut the [ __ ] up
the strength is there clearly yeah the
power is there like like go to his page
what's his name nick walker
ifb pro get get a video or like just
click on a there has to be like a
shirtless video somewhere this guy right
okay all right
a little kgb in this [ __ ] check this
out so if you guys are looking for money
not like a selfie video yeah right there
right there bring that ass back like a
boom boom boom boom dog
those lats are ridiculous
croissant looking boy
that [ __ ] is uh who's the buff
crab on spongebob larry i got no brain
cells i don't remember anything anymore
forgive me oh no it's christopher robin
yeah yeah that's what it is yeah the
crab from spongebob yeah christopher
robin
yeah he didn't even do a wrap dude it's
not doing anything
i'm pretty sure he's doing something i
think he's doing something bro yeah his
cycle is working so
that's why i don't really get like
being a stickler about technique
like lifting weights is lifting weights
you're still just using muscle you're
just pulling [ __ ] yeah like
sure you have a bigger chance of being
injured if you use like improper form
that's like the only argument
i think mm-hmm but also i don't know i
don't know anything about fitness yeah
you really don't yeah so but isn't that
true though don't you think no i i think
that as a
156 pound man
i'm extremely qualified to speak on this
subject actually
no i i do think at some point you just
have to move the [ __ ] weight yeah
you have to try yeah but if you do that
it's you're using some muscles yeah
they're getting broken down yeah which
means they're going to come back bigger
yeah i think simple science guys
i think as a former olympic athlete i'm
very qualified to speak on this
because i was the former olympic guy oh
you were yeah yeah
no no no i i think you're totally right
form to a point so you gotta move you
just gotta push that [ __ ] around yeah
you know what's funny i my instagram
feed
is just by the way what do you use more
these days you look at tick tock more
instagram more
probably they're like even because i
still go on my instagram discover and
it's all just like car crashes okay
and like wait [ __ ] and then um uh boxing
like tips okay i'm sorry i'm just on
mine i'm scrolling through it just to
see but keep talking my instagram
discover is a [ __ ] teenage boys
poster wall okay
it's like people lifting weights and
cars like oh i like waste call and
you know
uh
but there's this coach from new zealand
i've learned
like
so many little
important things about boxing from this
dude's uh like little videos
than
some of the time where i was you know
really putting the effort in he has such
a good way of explaining things
um oh [ __ ] his account is pad flow
he just sounds really stoic i think
because he sounds like he's from you
know he's got that new zealand accent
yeah yeah scroll down
yeah play that one pull don't push
[Music]
did that i started shadow boxing i'm
like oh my god
put me on some pads right now that's
crazy sometimes you just need that
little tweak to how you're thinking
about something mm-hmm
like in like golf is just so like that
just the stupidest little things like no
just look an inch in front of the ball
oh oh oh [ __ ] and then everything
connects you know
yeah then you fight you know something
else is wrong yeah yeah then i was
watching some other videos talking about
like pull counters
and
he was like demonstrating like
uh he's like
just put your foot back
back
slot ben
and you're ready to
shoot i'm like dude
dad is that you i don't know